ثلاثه ايام متواصله اجتاح خلالها جيش
الاحتلال مخيم ومدينه جنين ترك خلفه هذه
الاثار الظاهره في الطرقات والشوارع من
تخريب وتجريف كما ترك كذلك شعارات على
اسوار هذه المنازل لكن داخل هذه الاسوار
كان هناك ممارسات لم تظهر الا بعدما وثق
جيش الاحتلال ونشر جنوده على حسابات
بكاميرات هواتفهم ما جرى داخل هذه المنازل
هذا المنزل لال الغول سندخل اليه لنتعرف
على شهاده اهله حول ما وثقته كاميرات جنود
الاحتلال
داخله
بونين تفضل هي الا هذا المكان اللي كانوا
متواجدين فيه وياخذوا فيه الارجيله وه
وشابين الناس اللي كانوا هون بالمدخل وال
الناس اللي برا الاسرى يجيبوهم يكلهم
وحطوهم هون وغير الوسخ وغير الكلاب اللي
كانت موجوده هذا امبارح جينا نظفناه اثار
الكلاب جبنا تبع المغسله وجاب هنا ونظفناه
الكنب كلياته غير التنظيفات البيت كلياته
السجاد وهذا كلياته اللي رمنا رمناه غير
الابواب هسه بفرجيكم اياها كل الابواب
والمداخل كيف مكسر تكسير كله وهنا احد
الابواب التي قام الاحتلال بتكسيرها وهنا
الكتابه العبريه
تلاحظوها وهذا البيت والمكان الذي كانوا
يتواجدون فيه الاحتلال ويوجد فيديو حكيت
لكم
عنه هذا هو
الفيديو لذا
البيت
تلاحظون هنا يقوم بشرب المشروبات وهنا قام
بتفجير منازل احد
جيراننا اذا كل ذلك يعتبر ربما نموذجا
بسيطا عما جرى هنا في هذا المنزل كما في
عدد كبير من منازل الفلسطينيين الذين
اقتحمت منازلهم من قبل قوات الاحتلال
وتركوا خلفها ا كثيره كما تشاهدون هذه
الاثار من بين اثار كثيره ربما ما جرى هنا
قد وثق بالكاميرات بكاميرات عدسات جنود
الاحتلال الذين اقتحموا هذه المنازل لكن
قصصا كثيره سمعناها من شهود ولم توثق ولم
تروى تحكي ايضا الكثير حسن مسعود الجزيره
من مخيم جنين